this is the Jocko underground podcast
number 37. Echo Charles is sitting here
with me it's kind of chuckling what's
the chuckle for right you're you're the
man
that's not an accurate answer first of
all what are you chuckling because Brett
you're fired up today and I'm feeling
your energy and it's good man I'm very
happy it's making me very happy
Okay so
topic today there's a question that I
get asked there's a there's first of all
everybody always wants to know the one
thing right I could ask that question a
lot hey if there's one thing that you
could have known and I get it I get I'm
not I shouldn't have done the the
condescending Voice or the mimicking
voice because it's a legitimate question
hey if there's one thing that you would
have known when you
were in the SEAL Teams if there's one
thing you knew when you started your
business if there's one so there's
always those kind of questions
if there's one book you could recommend
there's those questions is there one
piece of advice that you right there so
there's all these questions right
and I usually try and
sort of gently say well
you know I I feel like I evolved over
time and I didn't just have a Eureka
moment and the Eureka moments that I
have had I put them into the book so you
can read especially leadership strategy
and tactics that's got some Eureka
moments in it right to learn how to
detach learn the importance of humility
right so those are things that I
remember happening
then you get but alongside the book One
occasionally there's one that comes up I
didn't feel like this was a Jocko
podcast level question but that's what
this podcast is for uh
best movie of all time
what's up what's your favorite movie of
all time again to me that's a tough
question because there's so many
different categories of movies okay so
what are your top five movies of all
time well again now we're how are we
rating this so what I I
framed this topic for myself in a
different way and the the question is or
the statement is what movies have I
watched more than 10 times yeah that's
good so I that was my thought
and then a kind of a little bit of I'm
not going to go too far under but like
why why is that movie particular and
then also I have to make a caveat here
that
I literally just thought of the first 10
that came to my mind and there's more
than this and I know I'm probably
missing some of my favorites or whatever
but
that's what I thought and then I thought
to organize them I kind of well as I did
it I was naturally I just naturally fell
into going in my past and thinking what
movies in my life have I watched more
than 10 times in chronological order so
number one coming out of the gate Jaws
yep Jaws we used to watch Jaws so we we
had a videotape machine back in the day
sure hell yeah betamax or VHS VHS
my dad started this company or attempted
to start this company called video
inventory protection VIP not a bad
little branding move there Pops I got it
so he in order to make this happen it
was the idea was he would go into your
house and video things and then if your
house burned down you go hey I got this
videotape in my you know my safety
deposit box at the bank we're good that
was his idea
business never did anything it was a
flop failure
but but he did buy a camera a video
camera and a video cassette recorder
which by the way was two different items
the video recorder was the size of two
or no maybe three shoe boxes
maybe four shoebox it was big you and
then it had a big thick cable that was
as bigger bigger around as big around as
your thumb and the cable went to the
camera which was
a big giant camera and the freaking
pictures were awful
and grainy and it sucked but we did get
this video cassette recorder
and you could record off the TV with it
so at some point in my life
somebody we we recorded the movie Jaws
off of TV because we had cable
so it was you know commercials and all
right
and we just recorded it was also rated G
so there was a bunch of parts that were
missing which I didn't find out until
later in life wait what was rated G
Frozen they've data adjusted it for TV
so there wasn't like no swears no nudity
because there's a couple nude scenes or
barely nude scenes or whatever some of
the violence had been edited out yeah
but we had recorded the movie Jaws and
we watched it freaking all the time the
other thing too is that's
that might have been the only movie that
we had maybe we had
no I don't think we had any other movies
recorded so that was it so like you had
one record what are you gonna play
You're Gonna Play that one record so by
default we kind of ended up just going
deep with jaws now it's an awesome movie
I'm from New England it's got a bunch of
hits a bunch of uh
what is it even when I was a kid you
know you're like oh this is like my
people right you know Quinn
so that was number one I remember
watching Jaws we watched Jaws countless
times man next up platoon
platoon like what am I gonna say when
that came out you know I wanted to be a
Commando out comes a movie raw crazy
and we ended up at some point I don't
think we I didn't get the video of that
early but eventually once I got older
and had my own video cassette recorder
and stuff and had a you'd go out and buy
a video from the store sure
platoon
and actually I think I may have confused
chronologically but Apocalypse Now
that one I know I had a recording of
from the TV or from somewhere I think it
was from the TV
bad recording you know those lines going
across it sometimes not all the time but
sometimes that's the tracking line yeah
the tracking lines man all that stuff
but Apocalypse Now Apocalypse Now may
have been actually I think that predated
me watching platoon over and over again
Apocalypse Now in fact I know it did
sort of reverse those two so Apocalypse
Now was probably the first war movie and
again here I am young kid wants to be a
Commando and here we go river boats
brown Water Navy Commando Upstream
secret mission cim and this is just a
dream come true and what's funny about
these movies platoon Apocalypse Now they
they were making these These are
allegedly anti-war movies
um
I've never met a friend of mine that
ever thought any of those movies were
anti-war as far as we were concerned
like those are why why we're joining
whenever I whenever I hear interviews
with some of those people the Hollywood
people that talk about the movie that
they made or the movie that they're in
and it was this anti-war thing I was
like man I guess I wasn't picking up on
that because when I saw Apocalypse Now
are you kidding me um
I wanted to rock and roll
platoon
if you watch that now you think oh my
gosh that's awful when you're 14 or
whatever dude this is it
this is it
say I didn't put on the list but Deer
Hunter is another one the reason I think
that because deer hunter's like a
psychologically scarring movie awful
movie
I love that movie I thought that was a
dream life you know what I mean I never
heard of Dear Hunter oh man it's a
freaking good movie man get him out get
him out what was the one with Chuck
Norris
I don't know I never got into those I
never got into those movies the the same
action movies that you like right now
that I don't like I didn't like them
back then that's weird yep I liked the
raw emotional crazy psycho war movies
like Deer Hunter
you've never seen deer hunter
psychologically scarring and when I
watched it I was like that's what I want
to do
so we got that going for us that and
that's you know I'm starting to go in
the tangent here but taxi driver same
thing you ever seen Taxi Driver yeah
yeah so Taxi Driver not didn't really
make my list here but that movie I was
intrigued by that movie
because Travis Bickel had been he's got
like a rocondo shirt or something hat
something like this and he was supposed
to be prior military and I was intrigued
by that thought dude that's legit he's
doing push-ups and disciplined
I was into that I was a little kid that
makes sense yeah it's kind of messed up
yeah kind of strange Raging Bull
um
you ever seen that movie wait oh no no I
know what movie that is though very
hostile movie I read something about
that movie one time that every single
frame is that right right word frame
every single frame in that entire movie
you could take it as a photograph still
image put on the wall and it'll be good
to go huh yeah I dig it so Raging Bull
I and I select fighting right for me it
was like you know but it's weird most
kids liked Rocky I liked Raging Bull
Raging Bull is not Rocky bro it is not
an uplifting story it's freaking
depressing what year is Raging Bull do
you know I mean ish about uh I want to
say 80. I want to say 80. wasn't that a
black and white movie yep it's black and
white but that's because Scorsese would
get an artistic yeah yeah he chose yeah
yeah it wasn't forced Clockwork Orange
you ever seen Clockwork Orange yeah
right up there man and this is where you
start getting like you know I had that
rebellious side I had that hardcore kid
sidewall Clockwork Orange was sort of
like a movie that they issued to and
you're a hardcore kid they're like yeah
Clockwork Orange get your drugs out mate
we're gonna go do some Ultra violence
that's what we were doing we were
carrying canes I had a cane back in the
day
I believe thinking I was a drug and
whatnot amen that's where we were at I
dig it a Cane's a Savage Weapon by the
way
okay hey you can legitimately walk
around in public carrying a stick bro
that's a that's a that's a thing you
know how crazy we were we we got these
little attachments for the canes that
you could
uh they would like screw onto the bottom
of the cane and they were allegedly for
when it was icy out you could put them
into the down position and there'd be
little spikes on the end of your cane
so Clockwork Orange drugs canes we're
getting after it watch that movie
countless times again probably not the
best movie for a kid to be watching when
I was watching it Full Metal Jacket goes
without saying right how I didn't end up
in the Marine Corps we're not sure
because when you see that movie and
you're a kid
you want to find the recruiting the
Marine Corps recruiter staff where are
you at I'm in where do I sign up right
which again is so weird because a dude
kills himself kills the Drone structure
of War everyone's getting killed and
when you're young you're like yeah cool
that's what I want to do so it's crazy
that these people make these sort of
anti-war-ish films
and yet
they'd make a kid pro war
they didn't get through to me yeah I
guess in a way
yeah so
that happens all the time with a lot of
movies so because what they do is they
show it's almost like I don't know if
they do it on purpose or not but it is
part of the ride of the movie where
they'll sure at the end the conclusion
they kind of reveal how
terrible or how bad or how scary or how
like serious certain things are but
meanwhile the whole movie they're
they're giving you imagery of like some
pretty awesome stuff so you ever seen
pretty much every gangster movies too
right all movie well not a whole movie
but pretty much all yes gangster movies
um you ever watch like wolf overall
Street
um Boiler Room
um I don't know even like I remember
watching like White Men Can't Jump you
know and like all these things they show
all this awesome stuff about certain
what was the downside of white man can't
jump I forget I thought it was just like
an uplifting basketball story no it was
like at the end he loses his girlfriend
or something like that I don't know big
impact yeah I guess no but either way
yeah maybe that's a bad example of the
downside in the but in the beginning
it's kind of like it makes you want to
do that thing because it makes it seem
so like hip and I don't know cool and
hardcore or whatever the case may be and
then yeah then they show at the end how
you know this is really some destructive
stuff or whatever and you're like yeah
cool ending but fast forwarding that
part yeah
whatever uh yeah no I guess you're right
I mean there's or there's at least part
of that is right because that's
definitely what happened to me I had a
movie on here because now I started
thinking now I'm kind of in the military
and there was a couple movies that came
to mind and by the way the 10 number 10.
that is a little excerpt of what we are
doing on the Jocko underground podcast
so if you want to continue to listen
go to Jocko underground.com And
subscribe and we're doing this to
mitigate our Reliance on external
platforms so we are not subject to their
control and we're doing it so we can
give you more control more interaction
more direct connections better
Communications with us
strengthen this Legion of Troopers that
are in the game with us so thank you
it's Jocko underground.com it costs
eight dollars and 18 cents a month and
if you can't afford to support us we can
still support you just email assistance
Jocko underground.com and we'll get you
taken care of until then we will see you
immobilized
Underground